laughs
[Music]
you know what's perfect about today
everything yep
all right how's the neighborhood watch
going let me see what's happening
nothing just pink lots and lots of pink
I don't hate the pink kind of dreamy do
these people work how can they afford
all this all right boys we're off to
work don't get too much sun Good Luck
running the world have fun in outer
space
wow these people haven't figured out
yeah they can have their mansions and
Astronaut jobs because we'll always have
pizza hey enough sitting around let's
Gear Up
[Music]
hey bro did you film that sorry am I
supposed to film all the stuff you do
because a lot of it's dumb
[Music]
what you looking at y'all what you
looking at
g'day fellas
that one seems cool
Broski abracadabra
[Music]
[Laughter]
August 2nd
get your tickets now